okay what do you guys think of the
phrase marry before you carry do you
think that's for you too especially do
you think that's true yes you should
marry before you carry 100.
I mean I have a kid now so I don't feel
like I could answer that question
you can still answer it if you could go
back to me me obviously in in the same
position I have a I have a five-year-old
daughter
however I fully believe in that though I
fully believe that's like though that's
like the right way right I think that if
I'm gonna say oh just because I didn't
do it
I'll be I'll be I'll be lying you know
what I mean so there's a level of
accountability we've got to have with
that situation and and for me that would
110 be be the ideal and it's like what I
said before
I wouldn't marry without the intention
to have a child yeah so when I do the
only way that I will be having my next
child
would be following marriage and and
that's at 110
um a bit so how old are you now I'm 28
now so you're 28 so you meet a girl
tomorrow let's say you're the same age
you wouldn't have a kid with her until
she's 32.
it's wild yeah no it's just interesting
because I really understand where the
guys are coming from but it's like the
one thing that we kind of have
conflicting is like marriage is a bad
contract but we want people to be
married to have kids so how do you
reconcile that
I think it's uh so we have I think we
all have our guidelines but there's a
level of like communication that you've
gotta that you've got to have around I
think that's like that's like the key
thing to it because obviously the female
body's changing the eggs are exit what
is it after is it after 30 they start
dropping I think 90 of your eggs are
gone by age 30. yeah but I think there
are a lot of why I think sometimes men
end up you know like choosing wrong even
though that's hard I know women are
crazy but I think that it's just so hard
for you guys to get women that like the
first nice girl that comes along and is
like yeah I'll have sex with you for the
rest of my life you're like okay I will
wipe her up and I think that's how a lot
of guys get stuck because they're not
looking at like character because if you
think about like what the standard that
most men have for relationships it's
like you know is she nice is she pretty
does she stick around like yeah I could
see how you know she ends up like taking
you for half because you know she she
could be off right that's why you need
to have these long periods where you
need to understand like like my mom I'm
saying about a year and all stuff it's
that's the whole point of that to make
sure that doesn't happen and the longest
the longer time you do it
um the more sort of tests you put
through then it will limit minimal your
risk of being in a situation and also
it's the fact that some guys just don't
have a lot of options and they don't
think they can get better so they focus
on this one person of who like you say
do you know what as well yeah I think
this is gonna as men
a year wasted is not that bad yeah and
this is not this is not even to sound
crazy but okay say a man's 29 yeah and
he meets a woman at 29 they get into a
relationship the relationship doesn't
work
the way the woman is looking at the
world at 30 and the same the way the man
is looking at the world at 30 is not the
same yeah so you could always bounce
back and I think with men are kind of
scared to get it wrong
it makes sense because it's such a bad
contract for men so it just sounds like
most men are willing to take the risk
even though there's nothing in it for
them really nowadays
if the girl puts in the time
and almost like as much as as like the
woman in me is like wow that's so much
time I understand it it almost seems
like it makes the deal more fair even
though it's unfair for men it goes back
to our argument that we feel we think
logically we think how can we minimize
the risk yeah because it's a safe bet is
this okay whatever the worst can happen
how much is this gonna damage me and a
man at 30 35 years old as we go up our
money gets more you know we get more
handsome our beards grow more you know
stuff like that so there's more there's
more stuff for us and of course as you
go up your options actually expand a lot
so you want to make sure you're right
making the right choice um can I ask you
guys a question you know how all women
aren't really taught to be wives right
now do you think that men are taught how
to find a wife identify a wife no
no I don't think there's a teaching but
I think we all have like different forms
of like Role Models around us so the
females around us that example I've got
a like my sister she she got married
then had her children bought a house
with her husband and and and and my mum
same scenario I think we we all whether
it's our family or family friends we see
and we we know really what we should be
going for because I think I think you
like literally have to sit down and talk
about this stuff I think that's like you
know reasons for the churches although
it's not it's not the best you know
statistics for marriage either but they
literally sit down and say like Hey by
scripture this is what a wife looks like
but I think that's how men are getting
Bamboozled it's like nobody like
literally sits you down as like okay
this is what a virtuous woman looks like
the fatherless homes I think are
contributing to that because I think
your dad is supposed to teach you
because your mom will lie to you you
know but I think your dad will tell you
yeah there's identifiers and men look
for them all the time but the thing is
women aren't actually told what those
identifiers are until much later on and
also I actually think the solution is a
woman should actually start looking for
something serious a lot younger instead
of using her younger years to like test
the playing field or like go on dates
and stuff when she turns 18 I think she
should actually start considering
looking for something serious in L.A I
just think at the end of the day like
women are a roll of the dice I I
genuinely think like
you're just never gonna know for sure
and it's just it's just a risk but like
I understand with how bad the contract
is today like why they want to take so
much time seven years if you laugh for
me that's a bit too yeah seven years is
mud I'll be honest but the problem is as
well though I think obviously you always
mention that and if people always
mention taking half taking half taking
half we like we hear about it like a lot
and the kids and and obviously like the
kids in that situation but one thing is
a lot a lot of men have the fear of odd
woman's gonna take half I reckon about
half the men there's nothing for the
woman to even take half of so that's the
first thing no that's the that's the
realness though because if we really
look at it and everybody has there's a
trial balance
um and we're looking at what's really
there first and foremost there's not a
lot so one thing I'd I'll cut like from
my personal situation my daughter's
favorite
so I think yeah when I was 21.
so the first thing was like right I've
had her out of marriage so my first
thing was security what's the first
thing so I was thinking right what can I
do what can I do so for me it was about
securing a um but her security was to
get a property so then I was thinking
okay cool but now if I marry that's
already pre-marriage so as long as you
sign it then obviously whatever you have
as a marriage going forward then I split
that's what I think it's fair that's why
I could never be with someone that that
obviously the theme I'm not working for
me that's not really I need especially
nowadays she needs to be earning like a
like a 30k year 40K year just just to
keep things ticking because that's
expensive now you know what I mean so I
think yeah we need to be put too much
and we put too much emphasis sometimes
on the whole taking taking the heart I
actually think that taking half and this
is probably unpopular I think it's worse
for the average guy than it is for Rich
guys because like I think of I think of
my dad if my mom took half like he'd be
fine even if he had like maybe she took
80 of his wealth like he's so productive
that he would just make more and like
maybe not as much but he would be fine
but I think like the average guy takes
him 25 years to get to that point and
then she can also take half also on that
point if
if um
I I had let's say I had a wife we had we
had two kids uh a girl and a boy and for
whatever reason she wanted to get a
divorce
I I would I would want them to have half
maybe even three quarters I'm good I'm
all right like I'm gonna be good I just
I need what I need and I'm gonna be good
and I can get out there I can still do
whatever I would want them to have most
because not not for not necessarily for
my partner
but for my kids for sure I would want
them to have all of that what if she
takes the kids and doesn't let you see
them oh no no no that's not that's
impossible
she's paid to do it do you have kids my
brother no no kids no so that's why you
say that that's why it answers that but
yeah okay but I hear
what is it there I forgot the person
that mad billionaire his wife got half
that's the one I didn't know if you
could do name drops I thought I'd make
it back yeah but um yeah we've got half
but the situation and the point where
they got married the financial situation
was not that I feel like genuine I feel
that she was due that the problem is is
like no but no but that's what because
we're talking about all these things
like loyalty and we're looking at all of
these lists and at the end of the day
she would have played a a role to to
enable him to do that
but look at their wealth after the
marriage if she played that big of a
role she would have made more money
after they got married where he his his
wealth increased by like fifty percent
like I just think like there's a
difference between like your wife doing
your accounting versus really building
your business no no 100 and 10 I think
yeah that's that's fact but
obviously the reason she got such a big
chunk was because at the point of
marriage to at the point of divorce I'm
sure there was like sporadic growth and
we can't there's all of these things
here she would really have had to
build up her man if she was the type of
person that all she was doing at home
was always testing build up a minute
you can inspire me but I just I I grew
up around like Ultra Ultra successful
man they were going to be successful
whether or not they had a girl there but
earlier on we was talking about testing
now I in my opinion I don't think Jeff
Bezos would have built that massive if
all if worst was at home always testing
testing testing like I just it's
possible Right but I feel that maybe not
a huge role but she would have played
her part in that and in and she was she
was looked after for that yeah it was a
ridiculous amount of money it was a
ridiculous amount she just got divorced
again from a school teacher yeah but you
know so okay as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do you possible